so if you're keeping track at home and
get a pen and paper because this is
worth remembering this is why you should
never criticize the FBI you think it's
your birthright as an American you can
do it wouldn't try it though
they might open an investigation into
you without your knowledge into
something appalling maybe it's beating
your wife maybe it's dealing fentanyl to
kids
maybe it's betraying your country in
some alliance with Vladimir Putin you
don't need to have done it but once they
investigate you they can always leak I
don't know two years later that they
were investigating you for this crime
that you didn't commit or at least they
found no evidence that you committed at
least you've never charged you for it
which sour system is close to art but it
doesn't matter because you're instantly
discredited don't criticize the FBI very
unwise